oh i'm playing a gm
oh i'm finally playing someone
[Music]
oh
it's someone low-rated though
i think all my opponents so far have
been low-rated there's a nature of late
joining
okay um stafford gamut against gm
maybe
i can't remember if i played this person
before
wow what does this move have this
we might transpose into like a
right liver type thing
g3 wait
we're going to have a fried liver with
g3 included
who does that benefit
g3 sometimes an awkward
move it's interesting
i want to play this move
because the knight's less defended
i mean there's a line with the pawn
still on g2
so i assume this is maybe a better
version hey it's toggy what's up tagi
there are a lot of people saying tagi
earlier
italy's here
wait what is this line
take the pawn it doesn't work
i want to play knight e5
95's okay
white wants to play this move but then
oh i have this move
hey
look at this move
i think it works
queenjig's queen knight f3 check
yeah
in the main line like two knights fried
liver the pond is still on g2
so white's really
regretting having played pawn g3
if only this game would make me a gm
there's actually uh there's a funny
moment in the
oh it was
2019 maybe
it was a u.s senior championship
a game between
[Music]
john elvis and was it larry evans or
joel benjamin
angel benjamin
john elvis vs joel benjamin
it was like
a very similar type of but slightly
different type of opening
where
they got like some reverse version with
pawn g3 included
and
like grand master
i think was elvis as white like
blundered a piece uh within the first
five moves
which maybe i'll have to share after
this game
so what is my opponent going to do
just let the time slowly dwindle away
not elvis elvis yeah it's not elvis
presley
uh there's jan
why no a
j-a-a-n and then elvis spelled
e-h-l-v-e-s-t
am i gonna win by dirty flagging
i don't think this will be considered a
dirty flag
maybe a dirty rage quit
11 moves let's go
i do want to share this uh this other
grandmaster game
okay well that's a nice way to end the
tournament
seven points
um
yeah i'll probably end up putting this
on youtube
i just want to put this one game on
youtube
beating a grand master in 11 moves with
a tricky
tricky like reverse fried liver type
thing
a very flavorful fried liver
so
yeah i wonder if it's already like
really good for black after queen a1
43 rows and trophies 17 are stalemate
traps though only five oh no my queens i
need to try harder oh i know my camera
is you in london but enjoyed your
interview in the chess magazine
yeah i was in a chess magazine in london
also i was talking about this earlier uh
my camera was running on its own battery
and it died
rip camera battery i'm gonna have to
recharge it
so now i don't have a face
but i really wanna still show this game
and it's gonna take me a moment
to set up the other camera so i think
i'll just go faceless
as i try and find
jan elvist
against
joel benjamin
here we go okay
so i just want to show you the opening
of this game because it was a funny
opening that the game i just played
reminded me of
and
people still hear my voice i hope
okay so they played um like a weird line
of the four knights with g3
and in this position
joel benjamin played bishop c5
and then elvis played the move knight
takes e5
thinking that it's just a reverse center
fork trick
the problem with this move
is that after
black just takes back
uh the original intention for elvis was
to play d4
but this doesn't work because after it
takes takes knight f3
and the pawn should really be on g2 here
so this was an instance of
i mean elvis used to be like top five in
the world
so grandmaster blundering a piece on
move five
like it's already minus five
and the crazy thing about this game is
uh
white almost like one like he fought
back incredibly well he played f4
um
[Music]
joel benjamin went a little bit
crazy with trying to get like immediate
destruction and
um
yeah it was a really really cool
position actually from the opening
anyway uh i'm probably gonna put this on
youtube as
kind of a
i don't know hopefully interesting
content between the game i played
myself losing my face
and then
a grandmaster blundering in five moves
so if you're watching on youtube in the
future
if you want to see the whole stream
check out the extra channel
this is where i post my full streams
so at some point soon i'll be posting
this full stream
and you can subscribe and
get even more content